hey guys what's up this is andrew for
jensenses.com so in this video guys we
gonna go through amc gme press action
and as usual i'm gonna update you on
what is happening in the global market
which is once again very important to
try to predict what can happen on meme
stocks we're also going to check what
the u.s 10 year yield is doing which is
a key indicator in this environment so
let's get into it
and guys let's start with amc papa so
mc is doing great today minus two
um the rest of the market is crashing
guys it's quite
strong i'm not positive
and about that i'm gonna show you my
view very soon
um
amc so i did my last video i think last
friday sorry i didn't update you
yesterday the day before i was very busy
um
but
i was telling you in my last video that
basically this trend line was still a
resistance right and we can see that we
configured two days below it and then
bam we broke out yesterday
so on the 17th
we did a plus 10
which was the rest of the market was
very bullish as well
and
this was a breakout but
low volume as you can see
okay here we have a nice increase in
volume so after this move we had to move
up true
here we have another breakout
but without volume the next day we ran
up
so today and we found
resistance uh this was this trend line
this trendline is not perfect
but it's the best i have all right
trying to just
you know connecting the highs that i
have here one two three four five
and we have this one and as usual use
always use the 20 period moving average
whatever the time frame this is the best
moving average to me
some traders use the 19
period some use the 21 depending if you
want to be early or a little bit late
depending if it's for your stop-loss or
your entry level but basically the 20 is
um the one that most traders paying are
paying attention to and here uh i always
use this 20 period moving average simple
to adjust my trend line so whatever here
we had a resistance and we arrived here
we were strongly bullish this morning
and bam
we got rejected as
once again it's not an amc related
issue it's just the rest of the market
crashing all right so
amc cannot buy itself rally i mean maybe
one day but
if you want to have a nice sustainable
rally you need the rest of the market to
be bullish too so uh right now what is
the situation if i only look at amc we
still have
uh here
this um
inverted hammer
that is a bullish
signal that gave us a nice move up
right now
we are hovering around the 13.5
resistance level we went across but we
didn't close above so we are back in a
kind of neutral area
i would say
um
and on the medium terms on the medium
term bears are still in control as you
can see we're still in this downtrend
we are below all the major moving
averages one two three we are below the
trend lines i mean we don't have good
news on the medium term on the short
term we had some good signs but now
we're back to neutral
because we don't have the volume coming
and we got rejected
so
you know we are now neutral on the short
term bearish on the medium term
and
bullish on the long term let's be honest
okay if you look from here we were at
two where 12 we still bullish in the
long run even if we are below the major
moving averages
as well
so i mean the bullish momentum in the
long term is
very um
challenged but
it's still here and i believe that if
the global market
goes better amc will pop pop up but for
now um the rest of the market is
crashing guys so we're gonna have a look
at that very soon let's first do gme so
we can have the same kind of analysis as
you can see
here the um
harami candlestick pattern the pregnant
woman in japanese
that got followed by a move up but once
again as you can see the resistance
level was at 105. it was tested once
twice and we didn't even manage to reach
this line that you have by connecting
here the highs if i go on a regular
scale ah you see sometimes it's good to
switch
okay so you see gme we're going to keep
the regular scale as you can see on the
regular scale things make more sense
so
we at least know where is the resistance
line it's here
um
so right now we are back to
[Music]
i mean where bears are still in control
we have here's some early sign of
bullishness we have oversold larissa
bullish candlestick we're missing the
breakout right with volume increase so
we had here a nice volume increase so
this is a good start but we need to
confirm that we take back control
and we need to close
above 98
100 and even above 105 would be the
confirmation so for now bez are still in
control now the global market guys but
it's disgusting
so what do we have here
uh
i personally missed my
short
my bearish trade
i was here guys i shared that with you
in this code
you know
sorry i didn't get
the right level like i did many times
before here i was just a little bit
above
i was a seller around 310
okay this was adjusted
we reached 306 307 so unfortunately i
didn't increase my shot position i'm
still protected
but my protection will protect me
until 270. so if we go below 270 i'm
gonna start to lose money
but for now i'm good
um this was a little bit my scenario
that i was fearing as you can see it's
still here one two three four so i think
we have completed the fourth wave we
could very well have tomorrow a bullish
reaction
again
we are there is a lot of uncertainty but
it would rat it would very likely be
sold again and what i'm fearing is this
bearish case that i just showed you guys
um
that might go to 230 something like that
so
the situation is not very nice to me as
long as we are below 310 on triple q
bears are still in control everything
might go lower
uh and us 10 new yield as you can see
i'm keeping an eye on this one guys it's
very important
because we have this breakout 40 years
resistance
as you can see and we are still above we
are now playing around the 280 285 level
uh so this is to me still showing that
we are at risk and i'm fearing that okay
if this happens we're gonna crash
bluetooth on triple cube probably go to
230 to 35
so
for now i'm still bearish guys
i'm bearish
on the market i'm bearish on crypto
it's not looking great
but
i have protection so i'm just gonna
you know
keep this position and take profit on my
protection around here
hopefully we won't go lower if we do i
might try to create another one here on
the retest we're gonna see we're not
there yet so this is a situation for me
thank you guys for watching this video i
hope you enjoyed it and if you did
please don't forget to click on the sub
like and bell button so you're gonna be
the first to know when i upload anything
new and stay close to shore see you guys